this technique is tricky
because we've been doing it from the
beginning
and our uks are not always as alive as
they should be
but you can still use the arts
principles to tell you whether it would
work or not
okay so my geometry
is a rotating spiraling
x so i have this
x and it is
rotating on itself and it's
traveling along a spiral as it does that
so it's not rotating in place that would
be a circle
and it's not staying still and doing a
spiral
and the reason for that is only the
rotating spiraling
cross continually
reconciles yin and yang throughout the
motion
as the person's height width and depth
dimensions
are being affected okay so
if i am doing ikyoura
and i'm going to go
here very common
because we think i'm going to pull it
under my center
and under my center is where i'm strung
and we picture this line
because i turn is a spiraling
rotating x but it is not
if you pay attention
it's a straight line
with a circle at the end
if you look at it from yin and yang it's
a pull
so we're going to experience two
resistance okay one is
he doesn't come with me don't come with
me
oh
let's say i violate the art well enough
that i'm able to overcome that
resistance
so i get it but it's
straight now with the turn
he can step under it and i can't get it
down
because i'm trying to overcome his
so quadriceps strong enough to get it
under me
but that's not going down
try both resistance against that pattern
which many of you have
tried so just
as if if i was strong enough to
take that line it's not the art
and even if i am strong enough so i'll
come over the camera to
see you and he has this point of like
and even if i'm strong enough with my
weight
it's not the r
it's just big man aikido which means not
aikido
so if you look
the arm is not rotating so some things
to tell you if the elbow stays on top
then the cross is not rotating the elbow
has to keep going over
also the elbow doesn't travel in a
straight line
it does go this way but it goes this way
in a spiral
so it goes this way
so we'll look at something uh
some cues if his elbow stays on top
i have the wrong line i'm not spiraling
the arm
if his body stays still
you see that's not it his body keeps
moving forward
so i'll show you let's get that leg
underneath me
you see it's not that i try to overpower
it
instead i'm going around this energy
this post right here
and it will put him on the other post
you'll see
now i want him to resist a second time
so when he resists here resist strong
this is what i get to take the other leg
okay
over here it's strong so i'm not going
against that leg
i'm going to take this over here and
point it down
then the other leg comes and now i
continue that
and you're going to see that i'm just
doing that over and over
and over again
so the technique in other words works
through his resistance
he wants to he wants to post he wants to
post but every time he posts that spiral
keeps going into
his chicago okay so that's why you're
not going to see the elbow on top
you're not going to see him stay still
everything keeps going around
keeps going around
[Music]
it's his resistance that creates the
shikaku
right here no over here
then again over here
the harder you pose the more you're
going to get the shikaku
okay try it again just like that without
the bottom pin
okay so we're not when i do the takedown
it's not that i'm
shoving him down on that process that's
not what's happening
he's already falling i'm aiming a
falling body
the lowering of me is just the same with
him
the lowering of me is not the lowering
of him he or
he was already lowering so he lowers
every time he takes that resistance
point
boom and he's going to push up on my
ground vector
and he's going to get a coq projection
down and then i just keep staying with
him
as he does that i'm not pushing him down
he just hits the the same projection
he's here
right we're here a lot of the technique
and he's gonna hit that same projection
of the ground he's gonna hit it on my
hands
so i'm going off bring him into that
pattern
right there that's why it's like that
it's a boom
not the steady where you're lowering him
his resistance his will to come up
projects him down okay
i come around
and i'm just staying as he keeps falling
so i'm not shoving him down
he keeps resisting projecting
so
[Music]
okay do not make people
fall down let people fall down
okay